how's the government my name is Barry
welcome back to a Aikido no yoga or a
night of the sacrifice we're gonna start
the fourth one it seems really [ __ ]
scary so let's just let's just jump into
it I don't know what I feel about this
press but I'm ready I'm ready as can be
can't you see I want to pee pits managed
to escape the go oh [ __ ] it's start
drying in action here doesn't it
well that is [ __ ] creepy whoa the
[ __ ] is that
alright heading out now problem here
alright what is that a radio transmitter
whoa hello friend you look like you have
better days don't tell me I do not want
you are all right it doesn't look like I
can do anything with it what the [ __ ]
all right pull it up book alright
don't walk inside him we're gonna walk
around here
all right this is going pretty well so
far
I can't complain this war looks [ __ ]
oh let's see what he's going is he gonna
go off the stairs I think it's a she
though could be a shemail
you never know with Japanese people Oh
job not a handle better don't [ __ ] with
Oh pick up pick up swing baby baby baby
baby oh yo yo yo hey hey hey pick a new
name any day job dad what the [ __ ] she
bite my ass chidden shake what whoa hold
anything anything digging it in it and
then it hey 911 yeah Jenna I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry
the [ __ ] is your problem I don't like
this bro
I'm just gonna under the head rod ah
[ __ ] skin hurts my balls I really don't
know why
well this is clearly not working out for
kids I think this has something to do
with this radio transmitter that I don't
really know how to use maybe I'm
supposed to turn off the lights and I
can see them now with this light I think
that's it I want to know what I'm going
alright look over there
yeah it's working that's why I can
Jania spelled strikes again I don't even
know - need to learn Japanese for that
[ __ ] i bench i [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] ma alright I'm behind you down
it's creepy I guess I'm not supposed to
go there where am I supposed to go then
I thought that I was it for sure
hi oh I can go down I can go down even
more right yeah I can
alright here we go abaca alright don't
[ __ ] with people right now you have to
[ __ ] with people
oh yes
data fall dead dead dead dead did it at
Denton did it I get it
whoever then an attendant don't go
alright this bloody door looks like it
has nothing bad in it oh she's climbing
up better hurry up that oh oh oh spikes
in' oh what the [ __ ]
oh the fire and then na over lemon I
know I'm not sure if I want open this
one oh oh oh
Dada Dada Helen fitness pants
all right we're going well what what are
you what are you pants you're an idiot
then I finished him up no I didn't [ __ ]
this is difficult bros and it's [ __ ]
stressful to stop rating at top grade a
god my ball turned because i can run in
the weirdest way huh giggles okay no
more and sorry about that
much info okay all right to the left to
the left like beyoncé's [ __ ]
sad in that one side [ __ ] dead I don't
[ __ ] remember Henry Oh job not a ha
they have fun
Oh what the [ __ ] are you doing doll
right now we take it real easy
hey I just met thank you who did this
Ranger but here's my [ __ ] number oh
nice han han back dad I can't even solve
one of these Carly J you don't help me
cuz you're [ __ ] gay
why can I go here nope I'm not that
[ __ ] I know that bit or we go in here I
saw that little girl I'm gonna follow
her dead dead dead dead dead dead
ohh job ha ha ha
[ __ ] me this game is just full of penis
all right we go in we go anywhere I'm
going above a line uh-huh Oh am I
supposed to go this place is [ __ ]
terrifying
all right boss
yeah we're going here we're going in we
going here just then we go here and we
hide a little bit and we cry in the
corner and then we go here la diabla oh
[ __ ] me [ __ ] me [ __ ] me [ __ ] me [ __ ] me
Jenn
[ __ ] that [ __ ] oh ja na yeah na I know
what to do nowadays
this is [ __ ] terrifying this game I'm
not gonna lie good heavens look at the
time Sarah I can't believe I died from
that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah whoa nice night
99.9999 oh I had a headache our home
it's not so easy I know you're looking
at me like oh this is inaudible a video
game I know how to play I'm playing all
right now I'm pretty sure they check you
know shut up stand up buddy hand it back
dad all right there we go cross funny
hey I go away giving the next one come
on hang out all day if you get a comma
one
oh oh okay we're good
Jesus Christ you're slow woman leash
yeah yeah when old a rose this is
horrible like that
there we go I got it wait until it
actually finish if there's the fourth
one I might just want to [ __ ] myself
okay running what that boy okay all
right hello okay okay okay that guy's a
headache I can't hang over one step
all shadows here again what do you want
ah
what [ __ ] ah can I please just pass all
right
easy-peasy anything out
hey enough is enough
there's enough is enough is enough
I'm walking like I'm taking a guy just
crapped my pants
what nah nah oh honey yes
what okay
they didn't let us redo everything at
least I'm the dumbest uh-oh wait open up
another bad Oh Danielle you think you're
funny I don't understand you
[ __ ]
I ain't Joe Oh sh ed he wanted to kiss
that was good
that was really good holy [ __ ] I was
scary dude it's only the fourth one are
you [ __ ] kidding me
there's 23 I think at least I said this
is dumped in a bit [ __ ]
monkey [ __ ] I want to say hey I'm a
[ __ ] man oh Sh
all right this is a prison that's
wonderful I love pretty good good thing
I'm not scared of prison or anything or
a slims
uh-huh all right work it serious I
opened in the most gay way I can it
seems like it's not so I guess we got to
look for a key tomorrow
dad dad dad after that what the fudge
what was that
was this book here before what is it
what does that say pears you are gay I
[ __ ] hate you
god damnit toilet why do you always have
to say bad things about me
alright alright whoa whoa hey girl
what's up what's up huh [ __ ] creepy
girls what the [ __ ] did you shoot you
say this again my [ __ ] Verona I don't
appreciate my own [ __ ] she's telling me
something that I don't speak Japanese so
I can
I can't think maybe she's like take a
[ __ ] before you come here pity otherwise
you should keep an eye just want to look
after you
what or I have to wait for that [ __ ]
nay at them madam half-off you it's I
don't eat me eat those things hate those
things
hey hey alright he still wants me I know
I'm delicious
okay that's okay with me if you wanna
eat dad that okay come on I gotta wait
for the eyeballs again alright I made it
somehow I just kept running cool but
what do we do now oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I
didn't think that far
alright this is it a room here what's
going on in here how I love I run in
here okay it's one of these not this
room's not big fan of this room oh
there's a girls day that's lovely
I'm just gonna go oh job love doing
Fichte alright oh this is nothing
hey I'm times I was following you Oh me
following you girl are you crazy
oh okay
and suppose father no no no no don't
define me that ghost is coming towards
me what am I supposed to do here I am
perplexed by this situation [ __ ]
go faster please why the [ __ ] did she go
hi she up here huh looks like I found my
escape sweet oh this is not a good dress
I'm not very good at holding back what
is down there actually I wasn't
following you what makes you think I was
following you crazy girl
you're crazy she saw me all along oh oh
she's evil now okay that dari Oh JA now
spring spring spring spring chilly
spring pick right back up
ha ha ha that's way better
alright what fine I'm fine okay what
fine we're not fine we're not fine
we're not fighting run run bears ah
night-night 9800 hurry up you
[ __ ] oh oh thank god
okay okay it's just two girls won't make
it
I'll make it watch this is text oh [ __ ]
you saw a
oh wow hutch
Oh Stefano what are you doing here
hello
oh it's here Sahara ha ha ha good Frank
hundred and forty eight oh [ __ ]
think it's time for me to take a break
everybody enjoy like a parody enjoyed
and hi that went well
like a vintage enjoy buzz as this guy
Homer it a now see you next episode oh
man
I [ __ ] love the music in this case
Oh